so I'm going to tell you three things
what the college is the political crisis
we face and how those two things are
related there's some perspective
students here tonight and some new
people so first I'll tell you briefly
what the college is it's a very old
fashioned thing and the fact that we've
lost sight of what it is is a sign of
the times it's a liberal arts college
and we think today that that means
studying a whole bunch of different
stuff it doesn't it means answering a
certain question I asked that question
of two perspective students both bright
and smart good-looking tonight and they
gave me one of them gave me the usual
answer I said what is the most important
thing to learn and he said well that's
that's a question he was he's a bold
young man by the way I think he's a dog
that will hunt as we say it Hillsdale
because he was so confident in saying
that's a question that cannot be
answered and I played at that time you
know that you placed yourself at the
logical position of proving a negative
it means you actually have to know
everything to say that it cannot be
answered but in fact it can be answered
the answer is found in the first book of
Plato's Republic for example and one of
my favorite conversations I've ever read
and one of the oldest conversations ever
recorded this ambitious young man having
watched the dialogue go on for a while
his name was Glaucon and he's like a kid
that would go to Hillsdale College or
he's like most any of us were when we
were young and full beans and he erupted
in the conversation I see the old
ballplayer artist sprinkle over there
James sprinkle his boy who graduated
from Hillsdale College to a lungo she's
exactly this kind of kid cheeky and
ambitious and wishing to
oh and get the answer and this guy
Glaucon intervenes with Socrates and he
says then show me
he says Socrates that I should not steal
even if I want the thing to steal and
even if I know that if I steal it I will
not get caught and everyone will think
me an honest man and I know further that
if I don't steal it I will be suspected
of stealing it at everyone who buddy
will blame me for dishonesty show me he
said that justice is good for its own
sake that's how the play is you know
Plato's Republic is one of the few
greatest books ever written it is a
wonder to read at any time in your life
and it starts with that urgent thing and
of course on the one hand that's the
most elevated question and on the other
hand it's not the most immediate and
constant question with which our
consciences are pricked every day
because it is the nature of the human
being that we are necessitous creatures
needing things all the time should we
steal to get them what wrong might we
commit in our own interest because our
interest presses us every day if we do
not eat every few hours we will begin to
starve and if we do not sleep in comfort
every night we will soon become
dysfunctional and in that respect we're
like every animal and yet in another
respect and this is a magical thing
especially when you think of it placed
in the context in which it is in a
magical thing something in us stands
outside that need and that is the voice
of our conscience correcting us all the
time and so Aristotle the student of
Socrates and Plato can say that the
it is the thing which calls us most
strongly and the process of becoming
good is the process of becoming a happy
human being and an educated human being
and so the most urgent question is the
question of the nature of the good how
shall we act and it is both for us the
ultimate question and it is the highest
question and I promise you if you go
look go look at the founding document of
any college founded more than a hundred
years ago and you will not find any I
promise that does not have at the center
of its mission that question of the good
all of them do our says the denomination
of Christians known as free will
Baptists along with other friends of
Education grateful to God for the
prevalence in the land of the
inestimable blessings of civil and
religious freedom and intelligent piety
civil and religious freedom that's
America's gift to the world you see
never achieved anywhere on the face of
the earth until this country grateful to
God we are for that and the the value of
the blessing is ago is beyond any
estimating and we say in the document
that sound learning is necessary to
preserve this blessing and we say that
this self learning will set up the
conditions to improve the heart that is
to say the moral virtues and develop the
mind of every student that is what we do
at our college and we don't do anything
else and if you want to come to our
College you should come to do that and
you will sign a pledge before you come
we call it our honor code and it says
that you will do
that and if you won't sign that pledge
we will not let you in and it doesn't
make any difference who you are and
every college in the land until about 75
years ago was run that way and how are
they run today do you know what AP
courses are you think I'm in high school
especially fancy suburban high schools
and and they give you college credit and
they help you get admitted to college
and there's a standard curriculum and
there's a series of examinations at the
end of them and they're pretty hard and
you know as things godly in high school
these days they're you know pretty good
and if you go you can buy it from Amazon
or I will send you the relevant
paragraph that I'm about to quote from
cost $9.99 and Amazon the current
teacher's guide for English literature
of the AP course which by that I
remember the power of that thing right
it's done by the College Board which is
some testing organization big powerful
deal and kids all over the country take
it and this is what they tell the
teachers about teaching the course this
introductory essay is written by an
English professor at Agnes Scott College
in Gorton in Georgia lively writer
pretty much you must be really smart of
the teaching of English literature
she says objectivity and sexuality are
out the door today we teach students to
find their own reality in the text no
doubt hoping which is by the way a
dangling participle
no doubt hoping that they will find
values to guide them through a mad mad
world what is the answer to the question
show me Socrates that I ought not steal
the answer is find your own values and
it deprives the student of the reason to
read the book we have a Shakespeare
teacher at our College he's wonderful
and he I said in one of his classes one
time I wanted to kiss him in the middle
of it and you know he's not even
good-looking and and he he comes in you
know and he holds up this book he's kind
of an ox guy he's from Texas I think and
you know Isis you know average we're
gonna read this book he said if you read
this book and he's holding up a bunch of
Shakespeare plays in a bound volume but
some of them yes and some of them no and
he says to them he says boy he says how
fortunate we are he says because for
those of you who worked on this we can
go deeper into this marvelous thing and
for those of you who would not you get
to meet this man and no one ever wrote
like this man it is marvelous you see
now the hard work of figuring out why
it's marvelous the hard work of finding
the truth that is hidden in it do you
want to know Shakespeare's description
of a mother's love
I saw it into King John in a play one
time it's one of the most effective
things I nearly fell over it was so
powerful the mother of Arthur the boy
who is one of the claimants for the
English throne
is grieving that her boy has been killed
in a dynastic contest and she is
grieving to the king of France who's
involved there you see and she keeps
going on about the loss of her son and
to her it's not the future king it's her
son and the King says madam I believe
you love your grief as much as you loved
your boy and she replies to him and I
can remember the look on the face of
this actress when she said these words
and the look was compelled by the
strength of the words she said I do my
grief sleeps in the bed where he lay and
it lives in the closet where his clothes
were it is what I have now because my
boy is gone and if you live in the age
when you think by an act of legislation
by a bunch of ignorant congressmen you
can change the nature of the family then
read that play and feel the power of
those words and read your Aristotle
where it says that the free soul of the
human being is a complex thing because
after all it is stuck in this body that
has these needs and it does take so long
to grow up and the fact that children of
human beings require so much care means
that none of us grows up without an act
of charity that asked that I last for at
least two decades and without that none
of us could live and so if you don't get
your education because you have been
deprived of the reason to get it you
might no not know the things that are as
plain as the nose on your face and we
live in a time like that and so you kids
if you come to our College get your
boots on it will be difficult and it
will be wonderful
this connects to the crisis in our
country something important has changed
in education and something important has
changed in our politics and these two
things that just so happens are parallel
exactly and precisely parallel I just
gave you a contrast between Plato's
Republic and Aristotle's ethics on the
one hand and the AP guide for English
literature on the other to compare the
sublime and the ridiculous
do it again compare them again when's
the last time you read the Declaration
of Independence start at the end it's
fun back there he mentions at the end of
the supreme judge of the world the whole
tone of the declaration by the way which
is an act of treason
you know and it's carries death
some of them suffered it so many of them
lost their property at the end they
submit their case after reading this
beautiful document and you know Thomas
Jefferson could really write and they
submitted the to the supreme judge of
the world for the rectitude of their
intentions say justice language justice
is real it's the Justice that said that
you King however well born you are may
name take art property because it is
ours and we are entitled to it and we
will no more let you take ours then we
will try to take yours because all men
are created equal exist and then it says
because they know the gravity of the act
they are committing that they say the
elastins in support of this declaration
we mutually pledge to each other Our
Lives our Fortunes and our sacred honor
now see that is an answer to glaucon's
question from the Republic no matter
what
we will not abandon the words that we
have written down there no interest of
ours and you can summarize every
interest it is possible for you to have
in the in the list of your lives and
your fortunes and your sacred honor one
of them was a farmer in Philadelphia
just outside in Philadelphia is near the
sea and he said to his wife the night
before he went to sign the document he
said met him he says tomorrow we're
going to declare our independence and
she said yes and he said I am going to
put my name on the document and she said
yes and he said we do live here near the
sea and they have the control of it and
he said yes and he said they are going
to take our farm and she said well then
find us somewhere to go so you see they
knew what they meant and it's because of
that grave thing that comes at the end
that you can judge the initial words
which are of course among the greatest
and the most famous political words ever
written but by the way ask an 18 year
old somewhere today to tell you where
these words come from when in the course
of human events which doesn't mean here
in 1776 understand it means any time it
becomes necessary for one people which
doesn't mean these people who at the end
are swearing their lives for the cause
it means any people when in the course
of human events it becomes necessary for
one people to dissolve the political
bands that have connected them with
another and to assume among the powers
of the earth the separate and equal
station to which the laws of nature and
of nature's God entitle them isn't that
a beautiful expression and you kids if
you come to our College I will ask you
to define for me the laws of nature and
of nature's God and when you tell me
that it's impossible to say such things
I will shame you and then when you
venture your first answer and your
second and your third and your fourth
and we give you more things to read and
then by the time you're a junior you
will begin to speak
on that subject the way Jefferson did
and you will know a joy that is very
great to extend the principle from the
Declaration Madison is explaining why
the Constitution has its structure in
the 51st Federalist paper and he says in
there my favorite part of that wonderful
book he says what is government but the
profoundest of all commentaries on human
nature if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither internal or external
controls on the government would be
needed in other words there's an order
of nature and at the top are angels in
God and at the bit in the middle art are
men and Jefferson writing about the
Declaration on it he died you know
exactly on its 50th anniversary of
course and a few days before he wrote
his last letter in his life to explain
it and he said it only means some men
are not born with saddles on their backs
nor others booted and spurred to ride
them by the grace of God angels men
horses and in the order of nature we are
all equal and have our rights Obama
rights
implicit in the Constitution structure
in the very idea of ordered Liberty was
a rejection of absolute truth I didn't
believe that what I mean god help us
what happened in the American Revolution
except a bunch of people by the way with
property and stuff at stake decided to
commit treason against the most powerful
man on earth and what did they do except
stop as Lincoln said all honored to
Jefferson who had the forecast the place
in a merely Obama claims to be a
follower of Lincoln all honored to
Jefferson who had the forecast took
place in a merely revolutionary document
an abstract truth applicable to all men
and all times put an put a statement of
utter illiteracy and it continues
implicit in the Constitution structure
in the very idea of ordered Liberty was
a rejection of absolute truth the
infallibility of any ideology or
theology or ISM that might block future
generations into an unalterable course
this is in the audacity of hope' in
other words a book written in the source
in the course of seeking power and with
the statement that there is no absolute
that should restrain its use we have in
this country right now a regulatory
bizarre do you know what a czar is
the greatest law ever passed in America
I think is apart from the constitution
of maybe the Northwest Ordinance is the
Homestead Act it is by the way very
complicated document it settles the
question of the western land and
organizes for its transfer to private
parties whoever they may be none of them
ever able to vote for anybody in
Congress or against him at that time if
they will just work on the land for five
years and it is so complex that it is
four pages long and it is glorious it is
beautiful
Lincoln signed it in 1862 it's one of
the greatest pieces of legislation in
the whole course of human history by the
way that's how I think we should pay off
the federal debt we should sell land and
government assets because they will do
better in the private sector and we have
a prayer the precedent for it
but I mentioned this because what was
the law of property under the czar at
the time that the north at the Homestead
Act was passed the law was that you
could only get any property if the czar
gave it to you and you could keep it so
long as he let you keep it and you owed
all of the produce from it and all of
your service to him at his whim whenever
right so zaardon is the opposite of the
phenomenon of American government and
what it produces is serfs and vassals
and not by the way people like us I am
the son of a schoolteacher from a little
town in Arkansas and I grew up taught
that I could do anything that I'd work
hard enough to do that is the opposite
of zaardon and the regulatory czar whom
I happen to know it's a shameful human
being writes in a book I do mean to say
that at a minimum what seems to be
government regulation of speech might in
some circumstances actually promote
speech freedom of speech words about
politics can in principle be controlled
because there is no such thing as an
absolute truth and that means that the
distinction between men and horses
diminishes and why by the way is it not
the doctrine that this old-fashioned
awkward idea of nature is his passe now
as Woodrow Wilson said the Declaration
of Independence is obviously an Indian
to say this he wrote it in congressional
government you can look it up the
Declaration of Independence is obsolete
it is answerable to a time accountable
to Newton but now we have Darwin and we
know that
societies are living and changing things
and so must be their governments and so
of course then your rights under your
nature are changeable things in 2003 on
NPR interview for goodness sake from the
record you can listen to it on the
Internet
senator Obama was asked what are we
going to do about this awkward Supreme
Court that won't let us do anything and
he replied you know it's kind of cool
what he said he said the Supreme Court
is not really the place he said because
of the founders put these provisions in
the Constitution that make it difficult
for us to do things that we need to do
like redistribution of wealth and so we
can only achieve those things through
community organizing now by the way the
guy has since taken an oath prescribed
in so many words in the Constitution to
uphold the Constitution of the United
States and defend it against all its
enemies and I wonder and somebody should
ask him not about where he was born
because you can't settle that question
they should ask him what is the status
of that oath
so I'll stay free of the strategic
situation briefly and I'll be done elite
and highly trained people intellectuals
mostly have as a group rejected the
principles of the founding of our
country they are now regarded as
obsolete and remember this point by the
way the claim when they were written is
that they are eternal and so if they're
obsolete now
they were not true then and if they are
true now they are not then sorry if they
were true then they are not obsolete now
and that means by the way that you have
to choose you can't have both they are
mutually exclusive and you must figure
out which one you want
by purpose or act a movement has been
set in train over decades not a
conspiracy it's open and it's not evil
in its own mind remember I've not called
anybody that well I did say something
bad about cass sunstein but but i was
draw it i don't mean that he's not a bad
man he is so very ill directed he's the
regulatory czar and their idea is to
overcome the awkward limits on the
government so that at last we can all be
a tight community and set everything
right and all live really equally in the
way that is by the way impossible for us
that's what's going on and it is
progressed to a point where it amounts
to an acuteness now because trillions
change hands and people are marching
did you see the advertisement of Scott
Brown ran the last week my heart just
jumped it starts out something like this
it looks like that video by the way and
I know how that video came to be I've
been studying the stuff I'm talking
about for 30 years and maybe I'm crazy
but I come by and honest I thought about
it a long time and I'm open about it too
right
and I do read the founding document of
Hillsdale College to be precisely in
conformity with the views that I hold
today else I would not be entitled to be
its head and I do believe that I believe
and understand the precise prescriptions
of the Declaration of Independence else
I would not be fit to address my fellow
citizens on questions of public concern
and these people by their own words have
set out to alter all that and sometimes
they pretend it is only a completion or
an evolution or an involvement of what
happened before but I'm saying to you
they are mutually exclusive and you have
to choose and what will come if we
choose the
way is that we will learn to live under
masters no doubt meaning good but they
are human and they have their needs and
the doctrine of the revolution you were
was you would give that power to angels
alone that is the first fact before us
today and the second is this it has
always been true of our country that if
our people ever go bad that is to say if
they ever adopt principles different
from those of the revolution then we are
finished because they are set up to be
the ultimate guardians of the
constitution and if you look at events
today it looks like maybe they have not
done that and then the third thing
follows they remain a people worthy of
an informed and educated leadership and
they have not added because the people
who govern us by and large with a few
noble exceptions have not read the books
and thought the thoughts that the
founders thought it necessary to read
and think to be fit to lead in the
United States of America and that brings
me to my conclusion and that is that I
am and a teaching business and I am
going to teach every student at
Hillsdale College with my colleagues and
every citizen who will listen and now
through our Kirby Center every statesman
who will listen the things they need to
know and that process carried on by me
and my colleagues and others will be
today as it has been in the past the
salvation of our country thank you
Thank You dr. Arnn we have a few moments
in dr. iron who's agreed to answer a few
questions we do have a couple of
microphones in the room because we are
taping this we'd like to get your
questions over a microphone so if you at
once you're chosen to ask a question if
you please wait for the mic anybody
you're nobody
I could pick out one of these young
people and make them do it you mentioned
a last ad Vibram but then which I must
have missed I didn't see it and you were
good at this I was going to describe it
but then I almost I thought it I didn't
have time but I thought about trying to
play it for you it starts out with a
picture of some revolutionary battles
and it says the first line if I remember
it right and race is here he's one of my
educators he follows them as you've seen
it have you seen it it I think it starts
out there's a picture of a Revolutionary
War battle and it says the first line is
Massachusetts has always been in the
front line you know and it's really true
I mean the do you know about the siege
of Boston and all that I mean the war
broke out in mass in Boston and that one
of the reasons they pick George
Washington I thank God they did and one
of the reasons they did was he was so
beautiful and had a war record but the
other reason was he wasn't from
Massachusetts and they meet you know
Virginia was a real big State down the
way and they thought we've got to get
everybody on our side here if one of us
John Hancock wanted it so the point is
that's where the revolution started and
you know the you know the first motto
you know have you seen the flag with the
broken snake don't tread on me you know
and you know the story of the letter
from the team to the American people he
was such a doofus
there are two really great stories about
this one is they said they you know by
the way everybody wanted to get along if
you read the documents in the progress
to the direct race of Independence they
are a process of people being persuaded
one by one by one because they wanted to
get along with the game they were very
slow to say they weren't loyal to him so
one point they sent Franklin over there
who was a deal maker you know he was
kind of a rascal who wrote moral
homilies and he was really quite a guy
and they sent him over there because he
was one who really wanted to get along
and they thought he can pax the son and
he gets over their knee sits down with
Grenville and Grenville who was you know
a silly goose of a guy you know and he
just never been over here right and he
said you are the children and we are the
mother country you have to do what we
say and Franklin goes to his room that
night and writes his first letter back
and he says there's gonna be a war this
we're not gonna do that
right see so the point is that's the
spirit of Boston and then the thing and
it describes it in three or four frames
with some really handsome words and then
at the end
Obama comes on and I don't think he's
called King George but he's pictured
pictured that way and this you know for
God's sake this is Massachusetts which
apparently still lives
in the last sentence of what you
concluded your address with you've said
this these things will be the I'm not
gonna write those words the salvation of
our countries it's okay
and my immediate all was do you mean
they will be or they are the only
possible solution will be you think it
will already change back to a
constitutional government and of course
accepted yes wonderful
that's applaud certainly you ever read
much Winston Churchill do you know how
he knew we were going to conquer the
Germans in 1940 when they had 200 and
some divisions the British had six
without their equipment and the Germans
started the Battle of Britain with air
superiority and the British were alone
and the Soviets were on the side of the
Germans he calculated it all up and he
said and when we have conquered his
conquer who shall for conquer we must
but he'll still has done a wonderful job
of expanding the knowledge of the school
and its mission throughout the country
through infamous but have there been any
other connections to be able to expand
to young people I'm sure that if you
were to look at the average age in fact
maybe you're going to dispute this of
the people who subscribe or who received
the publication they are older people
how can you get satellites if you will
of Hillsdale College throughout the
country without having difficulty with
the government and the all of the things
that come along with that thank you well
difficulty with our government is with
our government is our middle name so I
don't know we can get rid of that but I
I guess I'll say two kinds of answers of
that one is remember I actually believe
that ordinary people get their education
from their jobs and their families and
their churches and their stuff and the
stuff that they teach in college today
remember they begin with an invitation
not to learn it because they tell you in
the end the truth is just inside you and
doesn't have any correspondence to
anything outside and you know kids are
pretty cynical and pretty quick
I find especially if you tell them stuff
like that so I don't think that many
people are ruined by college so far
they're more ignorant than they should
be but you know that in you know it's
notorious fact that the students in a
college are more sensible than their
professors mostly
so so I don't I I think I don't think
that the thing that we're lacking is a
mass movement exactly I'll give another
example I don't think a finer person few
finer people than George W Bush have
ever been elected president but I think
it's just a recorded fact that in about
the middle twenty years of his life he
didn't read anything and it seemed like
that was true you know good guy but when
you're at that level making judgments I
don't think he ever fully figured out
what the problem was you know and
remember it's it's a gross fact but a
lot of gross facts are not visible until
you study a bit the government of the
United States has a different shape than
it used to have and that has happened
pretty recently why did that happen you
could say it happened by the evolution
of the economy but I think that's
nonsense why because you know I think
the guy who used to run Westinghouse is
here tonight right and he's a real smart
guy
I talked to him for a while and I and
I'll bet you if we ask him he will tell
you that the key to his success was that
he figured out how to push Authority
down alongside responsibility to the
lowest levels I know that's how I run
our college and our cost have been going
up slower than the rate of inflation for
a decade now that's mostly because you
know one time the accreditor said how
have you done that I said I didn't she
said who did it and I said everybody did
it and they said how'd you get him to do
it I said I asked them
you know I know I worked at it a lot I
tried to figure out how to ask them but
you know most of the things that I
learned in my life at Hillsdale College
you know most I know a huge amount about
19 year olds I really know a lot about
that you know how I know they told me
and sometimes they don't really fully
realize what they're telling you so the
point is this idea of centralized
bureaucratic government with complex
unreadable rules written at the top
that's not the spirit of anything else
in our country today except the
government and so I think it's been
adopted for some other reason then
because that's how things are going I
think there's a principle at work the
idea is this independence and separation
in the American government is the cause
of so much evil and so Woodrow Wilson
wrote in these words we have to find
tools to marry the interest of the
individual to the interest of the state
and I don't think it's any accident that
it's written at a health care bill that
60% of us are going to get transfer
payments and by the way if you can't do
arithmetic I will explain they're not
gonna be net gainers you see so the
point is I don't think George Bush knew
that and so I think leadership is partly
a gift of genius and I'm not I can't do
that I've studied Winston Churchill all
my life gosh what a phenomenon he was he
does never meet anybody like that he's
too great and I can't produce that but
what we can do is we can produce very
highly educated and dutiful people in
sufficient numbers to make a difference
and then you know we're going to start
pretty soon a request for so I'll answer
one more thing
a request for proposals is about to go
out from Hillsdale College to three
states where they have really good
charter school laws and they're credible
proposals will say that if you will form
a charter yourselves and receive the
obligations of that and we reach an
agreement we will do something for you
we will hire and pay your headmaster for
seven years and we will provide you a
curriculum and we will train all your
teachers and I think I think we might be
good at that because that's the business
were in we have a high school already
and you know I learned by screwing it up
how to run it and and and and I think
that if we do that and we're gonna do
that pretty soon and we might do that on
some substantial scale it might be many
of them and and I think then that's a
more of a mass impact and we're having a
constitutional Town Hall on January 30th
you've probably something out there
about it and a hundred people are gonna
get in the room and some of us are gonna
blow off to them but you can watch it on
the internet if you sign up so far
eleven thousand you know so that's
pretty good and then Primus is a million
eight and I can't stop it growing I
can't keep my budget the only thing in
my budget growing is in Primus and it's
going wild and we find a way to afford
it so there's your answer and remember
everyone in this room is a cause of
action in nature none of us is a horse
and that means there's just no
estimating what we can do look at
Massachusetts
so I see okay we'll try to how are we
done you guys want to go we'll ask a few
more and then we'll shut up to more
Johnson thank you sir for your own abasa
truth the thing I fear most is those
that want to have a constitutional
convention yeah what do you say to those
I know that a man named Tugwell worked
for Roosevelt and went a lot further
left than he liked he left the
government and he actually wrote a
constitution to propose the United
States not many people know that I'm
here that I I'm against a constitutional
convention and the reason is the old one
was so good and I could see it might
work if you excluded anybody who had a
PhD or had ever met anybody with you
know but in in general by the way the
the idea is get the old one back and I
would myself I always oppose
constitutional amendments except for two
I would repeal the 16th and 17
commitments and and and so I agree with
you that's the wrong direction
this one is the best one ever done
proven over and over again love that and
recover it and I even believe I'll tell
you one little thing we in 1854 the
Republican Party had its first
convention and published its first
platform document and it's a very
beautiful document because it teaches
the anti-slavery movement that you can't
abolish slavery except by constitutional
means and it proposes the means and the
means is we won't touch it in the states
where it exists but we will forbid it to
go any further into any federal
territory and that was at that time most
of the land and that's the platform that
Lincoln later ran on and that platform
was written in Jackson Michigan by 12
people and two of them it does just so
happen worked at Hillsdale College so we
you know are gonna write another one
just like it about a constitutional
model platform political party and were
going to publish that pretty soon and
that seems to me a way to
work your way back to the to the good
one not try to make up another one okay
so this one and then one more um I just
have a quick question about your
philosophy about who you choose to be
speakers whether they be for the
imprimatur other speakers at your school
I happen to have gone to one of those
Ivy League schools that we don't like to
talk about anymore in our household my
husband went to another one and I just
met another Ivy Leaguer in my row and he
doesn't seem to be too thrilled about
his school and one of our big complaints
about the school is they never have
diversity of their speakers there's
always very one-sided our son went to in
New England College and he did a poll
and he realized that there were only
four Republican professors among the 465
I don't know how many there were but
anyway there were very few and I thought
okay I happen to really like Hillsdale
College because I agree with you but I'm
thinking maybe Hillsdale College doesn't
they do on the other end what our
schools are doing what we don't like I'm
curious about your philosophy yeah okay
well I don't use the word philosophy for
things like that but I'll tell you what
our principle is first of all so I give
you two kinds of answers and they seem
to cut in different directions the first
is the the purpose of a college is not
diversity its truth for example if you
say the sentence which the president of
this which the president of the
University of Michigan is forever saying
I wrote her a letter about it once if
you say the sentence that the University
of Michigan's purpose is diversity the
word University and diversity don't work
together right it's stupid but but now
how do you get to the truth and the
answer is our Constitution reader is on
the internet and you will discover if
you find it that we believe that the
Constitution of the United States is the
greatest instrument of government ever
written and that there is about as much
space devoted to the P
who urged its rejection is those who who
urged its passage the anti-federalists
and the Federalists are both represented
our college is a unionist college
abolitionist college nobody had a bigger
part in the civil war than we and we
read the confederacy in our reader and
we think that progressivism is a
terrible and dangerous thing and we have
a whole section of the reader just on
that original sources by the people who
wrote it we have four on-campus
conferences a year and they're on a
topic and we invite the best people we
can find to debate that topic not
necessarily equally to represent the
sides because sometimes this one side is
stupid and we don't feel but we counted
it up not long ago we counted it up not
long ago because we were asked a
question and as far as we could tell
over the last three or four years there
have been more Democrat speak at our on
campus conferences and Republicans so
remember the worst like like for example
in a college you you have to have this
rule to get anywhere you never I always
say this to the freshmen we are not here
to agree to disagree if we disagree
somebody's wrong and this is the place
where we get to the bottom of that point
so it is the scholars point to conceal
no significant fact against yourself and
we try to follow that procedure
okay one more and then we'll shut up the
man who looks like my corner who works
in my office doc darn my name is Jerry
Sawyer I'm from Fort Myers Beach I was a
student for nine years a professor of
English for many more you made the
statement that the students tend to be
more sensible than the professor's I
I agree with that mine are let me be the
devil's that get for just a moment okay
since 1800
the philosophy has started out
naturalism distinguish between
philosophy and politics for years the
Perth the Academy has been teaching
naturalism the climate was the election
of Barack Obama the character of America
collapsed at that time as a result of
this continued Viraj here's my point I
think that with the election of Scott
Brown a couple days ago in Massachusetts
we've won a temporary victory but in the
long run I don't think it looks so good
I think that academia is carrying this
not just United States the world with
naturalism that thing is all there is
and I don't think it looks so good I'm
being the devil's advocate respond if
you wish well
okay now so I guess I was fun this way
the gloomiest a say that I know of that
when Central Road is called mass effects
on Modern Life
and it sounds a little bit like what
you've just said he talks about how
everything is so big now and everything
is so organized and people are so
comfort comfortable and everything is
provided for them in canned opinion
entertainment and the corporate world so
uniform and the same and it's so awful
and he says that this phenomenon finds
its highest state of perfection which
doesn't mean it's different in kind in
Bolshevism which he says would reduce
human society not to the condition of
the bee because it won't be able to make
any honey to the condition of the white
and that's very dark right and then he
says the next paragraph and I can quote
it pretty close but human nature is more
intractable than ant nature the
explosive variety and liberty it
presents makes it an in changeable fact
that human beings are easy to lead and
hard to drive so what I think is I think
that what happened in Massachusetts is
not a passing phenomenon it is an
explosion not of naturalism but of
nature the nature of man